[Music]
welcome to the reason Round Table your
weekly libertarian podcast that worries
more about the gas bags floating up out
of Washington DC man
I'm Matt Welch joined per common law by
Nick Gillespie Peter suderman and
Catherine mengu Ward happy baseball
season everyone hey Matt well howdy
happy Monday
yeah that's right Peter so a lot has
transpired since the State of the Union
speech last Tuesday if you remember it
at all
um for instance Rihanna got pregnant and
apparently we've started uh an
Intergalactic War but there was a
critical and very chaotic uh
three-minute passage of President Joe
Biden's speech that carried over into
the following days into this week likely
next month most of this year and why not
the presidential race in 2024 as well
uh it started off by the president
stating quite falsely
that Republicans want to take the
economy hostage unless he agrees to
their economic plans which include
making the Social Security and Medicare
programs sunset uh Republicans erupted
into House of Commons style hollering in
response Biden then shot back that he'd
be happy to give anyone copies of what
he called The Proposal
uh than a apparently Cruella Deville
dressed Marjorie Taylor greens started
shouting liar
um Biden said oh we all apparently agree
that Social Security and Medicare Cuts
aren't going to be part of the debt
ceiling negotiations and then everybody
Rose to their feet and rapturous
Applause and Our Idiot political
commentariat gushed about how Biden had
laid a masterful trap for Republicans
Kaboom in Truth uh House Majority Leader
Kevin McCarthy the Bakersfield Comet had
already agreed the week before to keep
entitlements out of the debt ceiling
discussion Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell has been loudly rejecting any
notion of sun setting Social Security
Medicare since last March and in fact
the author of the so-called proposal to
do so Senator Rick Scott from Florida
also said again last March that quote no
one that I know of wants to Sunset
Medicare or Social Security end quote
Scott's so-called blueprint which Mitch
McConnell vociferously rejected upon
arrival last year simply said as an
aspirational goal not some kind of
retroactive rip it up quote all federal
legislation sunsets in five years if a
law is worth keeping Congress can pass
it again end quote and of course Joe
Biden used to say stuff like that as
Rick Scott was uh cheekly uh pointed out
on Twitter yeah I I wouldn't uh use the
term cheekily with Rick Scott yeah he
doesn't even have cheeks he looks like
Fire Marshal Bill from uh
the old and Living Color comedy sketch
there is uh no doubt that uh President
Joseph Wright Brighton Bob and had the
second made
um very effective politics out of the
whole stunt the Peter did he really save
Social Security in Medicare last week
no
yeah no he didn't you really why do you
say that what I heard he did though
Peter
you may have heard wrong Catherine
Maggie Ward
I don't know where you're getting your
information from
it's
but some of us
did you find that that stash of
Quaaludes yeah some of us read the
reports produced on a regular basis
by the Medicare and Social Security
trustees and the Congressional budget
office and what those reports tell us is
that in about 10 or 12 years depending
on who you believe
Social Security is going to be insolvent
which means that benefits will
automatically be cut by 20 to 25 percent
across the board
so that means that if Joe Biden
successfully prevents Republicans from
touching Social Security
then all of the beneficiaries who at
that point will lose about a quarter of
their benefits immediately now these are
estimates it might be a little bit more
or a little bit less
but that's Joe Biden's plan so far as we
know it right now now he did say that he
has a forthcoming plan that's going to
extend the life of the trust fund for
maybe another 20 years or so but we
haven't seen the numbers on that and
historically
those sorts of plans have been a little
bit Rife with what we might call
just like numbers that don't uh
it's uh the official term and Joe
Biden's America is malarkey with numbers
that don't add up and are kind of fake
so right now that's Joe Biden's position
is that we shouldn't do anything and we
should wait a decade or so and then let
Social Security cut Itself by 20 to 25
percent immediately which would affect
which would affect the people who are
most vulnerable the hardest because
social security goes to people who are
quite well off as well as people who are
who are struggling
uh Peter before I uh lateral to Nick uh
about a related issue about all this can
you give us any sense of the like uh
like amount right so the the the the day
happens we are insolvent day happens
um how much money or how do you
characterize the amount of money to
uninsolvent it like what it would was
there is there a Dollar figure on it is
there like a a tax figure on it is there
any way to sort of wrap our puny matte
Welch sized brains around this costume
so to understand this it's helpful to
understand how we pay for Social
Security right now and so I'm gonna I'm
gonna bracket this by saying we don't
actually pay for Social Security right
now we have a trust fund that is fake
but let's for a moment just just ignore
that and assume that the trust fund is
kind of real or at least real as an
accounting fiction and so the way we do
this is that we have uh we have a
payroll tax on the first hundred and
forty seven thousand dollars of income
that people uh it's actually a hundred
and sixty thousand in 2023 and it's gone
up since 2015 from like 200 uh from 118.
so some of us are still living in the
past where it's 20 22. and it's a better
pass I haven't seen the Super Bowl yet
so for me so did 2023 even really we're
not even in 2023
uh and so right okay so it's about so
the first hundred and something thousand
dollars of income uh is uh charged a
payroll tax which is typically split
between an employee share and an
employer share or if you're
self-employed you pay the whole thing
obviously that split between employer
and employee is itself kind of fake
because it mostly sort of ends up being
passed on uh but that's sort of but
that's how it's How We account for it
and so uh in order to make Social
Security solvents for the next 75 years
which is sort of the the long run
Horizon at which point we don't even
think about it anymore we would need to
raise an additional 3.4 percent of all
payroll over that period of time uh
according to the trustees and so there's
a bunch of different plans uh to extend
the life of the Social Security trust
fund
um if you look at the Congressional
budget office uh uh they've got a a
whole Suite of options that you can go
and look at but I think the one that we
should talk about most is is raising the
payroll tax cap rate so basically um
uncapping uh income there right so the
and the one of the prevailing uh ways to
do that is not actually to just say that
all income over 147 or 160 000 would be
taxed but instead to say well we're
going to keep that cap at 150 or 160.
but then we're going to start taxing
income over two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars and the thinking there
is that that that will make sure that
only people who are making more than 250
000 a year I.E the rich in political
parlance
are subject to the the new um to the new
tax uh and if you do that the
Congressional budget office reports that
there's going to be some economic
effects if if that happens because what
happens if you start taxing all of that
money
um a lot higher than you're taxing it
right now uh one thing that happens is
people earn less uh per extra dollars
that they earn over 250 000 and so that
just means they're making less period
even if they're making the same amount
of money pre-tax right so if you're
making three hundred thousand dollars or
or whatever that is uh per year you're
gonna be earning less even if there's no
other change but because people are
because each marginal dollar is worth
less the Congressional budget office
also says that people will on average
work less
because people will be somewhat less
motivated to work
uh because because working is is worth
less for them and so there are economic
effects and there are there's an
economic drag to to to taking a path
like that into increasing taxes
um even if you do end up sort of making
the the Social Security trust fund
somewhat more solvent uh for the next
several decades as a result
uh let's talk more about taxes and drag
Nick
um back uh when uh you entered the chat
yeah that's right meatball Ron just
entered the chat uh uh back in your uh
Carefree youth uh Nick when you were
doing a lot of uh uh drag uh and taxes
oh yeah yeah sure you wrote a great
piece with Veronica duruji with the
headline the 19 solution which pointed
out that the historical size or share uh
let's say of uh how much the federal
government was gobbling from GDP was
around 19 that we deviated above that 10
years ago and you guys sounded the
warning that that would uh threaten to
create both political instability and
drag on the economy so where are we now
with those numbers uh how will the
short-term victory of uh Joe Biden's
autopilot uh affect the ratio and what
what would might those side effects look
like
so uh according to the CBO between 1972
and 2021 so this comes up to last year
and includes two massive years of covet
spending outlays by the government
average 20.8 percent of GDP average uh
Revenue was 17.3 percent it's estimating
for the next 10 years outlays will be
23.2 percent and revenue will be 18.1
percent so essentially we have just we
are looking at spending substantially
more uh money as a percentage as as a
ratio of the economy than we ever have
in peace time uh there was a spike
during World War II where spending per
GDP as a percentage of GDP reached 40
percent but um you know where this is
Uncharted Territory where we're going to
have you know massive persistent
completely unrestrained spending we
might well have record Revenue coming in
but the annual deficits and the national
debt will just continue to grow at the
same time more people as a percentage of
the population will be above 65 so
they'll be collecting Medicare and
Social Security uh probably working less
so you know this is it's a really really
bad situation
um and the worst part of it and you know
Matt just to push back a little bit on
you talking about uh Joe Biden I mean
it's it's important that the Republicans
all leapt to their cloven Hooves to
applaud the idea that they are not going
to cut old age entitlement absolutely uh
whatsoever and so like what Peter's
talking about all of that spending
Social Security on things like Social
Security Medicare are just going to take
up more and more resources
um and you know that is it's not going
to be a productive uh decade looking
forward uh the other thing that I'll
throw in for Social Security and I have
a short video op-ed that'll be coming
out in a couple days about this but
according you know you can find
different studies that find different
things but all of them come all of them
basically agree that if you take the at
12.4 percent of uh income that gets
taxed the payroll tax that goes into
Social Security uh in 2016 the tax
Foundation uh did a study where that
worked out to about 20 or 21 000 a year
for the average so an average worker
paying in Social Security would get
about twenty one thousand dollars a year
from that and if they had put 10 of
their income into a conservative typical
Ira uh or 401k plan that was split
between a 60 stocks 40 percent bonds
they would have gotten three times that
and virtually every analysis of Social
Security shows that it is a generally
weak output uh for you know for people
particularly even average workers
um so it's you know we're we're doing
everything we can to sustain A system
that was passed in 1935 started cutting
checks in 1940 in a radically different
economy in a radical different world
when people were living shorter lives
and old people to be old was to be poor
we are um you know it's mind-boggling
and I mean it's you know I think a lot
about how Jar Jar Binks was a senator in
Star Wars and like you know when you
look at the State of the Union it's Jar
Jar Binks in filling every seat there
they might have different predilections
and and stupid focuses but they're all
it's not gonna cut Social Security
yeah no I was all about ready to
congratulate Peter for not taking the
bait and you just took it um
gonna revoke that congratulations do not
congratulate do not congratulate
uh Catherine um what are your least
favorite parts of the Biden Maga
populist convergence as expressed
especially uh at the State of the Union
last week and there were so many parts I
think you know we talked about some of
them in advance just the the increasing
convergence in terms of
um the willingness to use federal power
to manipulate all kinds of commercial
transactions and um the sort of junk fee
stuff was uh a great example of that
just
um classic classic populism right just
like taking kind of harnessing people's
anger
at a at a you know a thing that was just
not the president of the United States
business like
Resort fees for crying out loud and uh
and rallying people around that but I do
think
you know what we saw
at the State of the Union was just a
bunch of people
realizing for the first time a thing
that those of us who have been watching
this question for a long time already
knew which was that no one wants to cut
Social Security or reform it in any way
and I I guess it makes sense to me that
there was still a widespread belief that
there were two sides to this issue
and the you know the fact that Joe Biden
managed to get on TV that there is there
is only one side that everyone agrees
they're going to do nothing as long as
humanly possible
is you know it had that it had that ring
of like
yeah man duh to those of us who have
been watching but I get it that other
people thought
maybe Republicans are going to try and
solve this problem and whether they
thought it was a good thing or a bad
thing to solve it by quote unquote sun
setting which is also an amazing like
it's such a perfectly crafted term for
people to misunderstand like when the
sun sets it goes away Matt it's gone
forever that's how the Sun works or so
like I don't understand like
um it's a technical term about you know
that that people crafting legislation
use it does not mean the same thing as
permanently abolishing or defunding or
eliminating Social Security and everyone
involved know that knew that Joe Biden
most of all and he exploited that
confusion and misunderstanding me so
worried because that fireball will never
come back stop I will kill you yeah that
is just knife it's too much the as a
matter of fact as you mentioned that
Catherine it reminded me that Jimmy
Carter's 1979 speech which I wrote about
last week
it's kind of the timeline analog to
Biden's speech in terms of where he was
at in his first term he comes out in
favor by name of sun setting programs we
need to uh stop the regulatory you know
beast from just fattening forever and we
need to like figure out what's going on
uh and uh and such that these things and
I don't think that he's portrayed as a
monster
um
to be clear I'm Pro I'm Pro Sunset both
Pro actual sunsets
on setting up legislation like that
would be a perfectly good mechanism to
keep these policies in check to
routinely review them for whether they
still fit the world that we live in it's
just it's not
it's not what actually happens it's not
what actually works and it isn't going
to happen I
I want to point out Matt because this
meme I forget exactly how it entered my
timelines but uh over the weekend it was
Heavy heavily there which is that and
I'm paraphrasing it but that Jimmy
Carter speech is closer to Pearl Harbor
than it is to today yes and uh you know
it it is just amazing that people are
not talking about the actual
transformation of old age entitlements
into something that is targeted and
helps poor people regardless of age but
let's just say Okay old people you know
because I've lived through a lot of
they get special benefits just for being
65 like I mean it it is just it's
mind-numbing
um and one of the things that Jimmy
Carter was you know bitching and moaning
about was that Ronald Reagan was going
to destroy the uh you know uh Social
Security because it was part of FDR's
New Deal and Ronald Reagan left off his
touting and this is actually I believe
in the 17th uh 19 solution story that
you referenced earlier but Ronald Reagan
said that his greatest achievement as
president was securing funding for
social security and Medicare for the
Next Generation which worked out to be
about true towards the end of his
presidency he jacked up payroll taxes
that was part of a big tax package right
at the end of his thing and it's like he
God damn him for that because he used to
be he used to be critical of uh of
mandatory Social Security
Peter Catherine mentioned that she kind
of understands you know people being
surprised that to learn that there are
Republicans jumping up and down on their
cloven Hooves uh plotting the not
touching um wearing Ric Flair style
clothing by the way I loved Marjorie
Taylor Green's rolled fur coat she
explained it from she was dressed up as
the balloon it was her balloon costume
we're in a pretty good place uh
politically is what I'm trying to say
but uh yeah uh Peter um so again
Catherine said that uh that it is sort
of understandable that people would be
surprised to learn that Republicans
actually are not in this day and age all
that interested in holding the debt
ceiling hostage over cuts and Social
Security and Medicare
okay so let's let's let's give people
um a slight break on this
but how many damn political journalists
and commentators including people who
you forward in the slack every damn day
um have were out there in September in
October and November of 2022 saying the
midterms the biggest story before the
midterms is that Republicans are totally
going to hold uh the economy Hostage to
force social security cuts total
at the time total now
um and these are people who were
supposed to be sophisticated observers
what do we make of that well I think you
wrote about this and I think part of
what we make about it is that Democrats
as in people who are at like actual
elected officials but also their
boosters in media Democrat aligned uh
journalists uh pundits want this to be
the Republican position and they want it
to be the Republican position because
they view it as a politically beneficial
to Democrats that's why Joe Biden did
what he did at the State of the Union is
because he believes it to be politically
beneficial and frankly if that were true
it would be correct and to the extent
that people believe that it is true it
is correct like I I just I I agree with
the short-term political calculus that
what that Democrats want to demagogue
this issue and they think that doing so
is good politics for them and I like
just on the on the getting people to
vote for the merits I think that the
answer is pretty clear people are going
to vote against Republicans uh for this
but Mitch McConnell has been saying
we're not going to do that and the and
the the Rick Scott plan which is the the
sort of the The Source material for the
Democratic argument that this is the big
thing that that um that Republicans want
to do that that is not something that
Republicans stand by at all I mean there
was a quote just within the last week in
USA Today from Mitch McConnell uh who is
you know the top Republican in the
Senate unfortunately that was the Scot
plan that's not a republican plan
Rick Scott is to be clear a Republican
senator but this is this is what
Republicans are doing now is distancing
themselves from any effort to make any
kind of meaningful changes to
entitlements despite the fact that as I
have said many times uh in about six
years or so one of the big Medicare
trust funds is going to be insolvent and
in 10 or 12 years Social Security's big
trust fund is going to be insolvent as
well and somebody's going to at some
point have to step up and do something
and I think that that's something that
is going to be done is not something
that anyone on this podcast is going to
approve of it's going to be a sort of
tax increases and budget gimmicks some
combination of the two possibly some
very token spending cuts you know stuff
that is essentially trivial that doesn't
really matter and that's what's gonna
happen and it's going to extend the life
of Social Security and or Medicare for
at least a decade or two they're going
to kick the can down the road and that's
going to be that and I think that that's
the way the politics are shaping up and
I think that that's you know sort of uh
you're the question is about is about
the sort of the Lefty journalists who
are political analysts who are trying to
say that Republicans are just desperate
to cut entitlements I think you could
say that you that was more true in an
era when Paul Ryan was a very prominent
Republican and when Paul Ryan was a you
know was a one of the Republican leaders
but it's just not true anymore
Republicans under in the in the Mitch
McConnell and Donald Trump era have
basically given that up and that was one
of the lessons that Republicans took
from the Trump presidency is you have to
say we will never cut Social Security
and we will never cut Medicare those
things are totally off limits
they're the third rail of American
politics uh nick uh I know you have
special fondness for uh the Republican
backbencher chorus of thumbs Downing
crazy costume uh nuttiness what
what do you make of that I mean we're so
it's Joe Wilson you lie was 2009 and it
was like a big deal at the time and like
wow he broke decorum and he apologized
and there was a there was a a vote
against him like censuring him
um and like we're just not there anymore
what what do you think about this sort
of Republican uh uh worldwide uh
Wrestling Federation thing that's going
on right now yeah I I think it uh is
unfortunate because it's if if the lack
of decorum uh you know was was motivated
by a need to make things better that
would be one thing but it really is I
think it's just reflective of incredibly
like double-digit IQs among people like
Marjorie Taylor green and Lauren bobert
uh and Marjorie Taylor green has emerged
as like a leader of the Republican party
at least rhetorically because there
aren't any legislative leaders I mean
somebody like Kevin McCarthy you know to
call him I'm an empty suit is really to
diminish you know the the way suits look
on mannequins I mean they're kind of
nice I mean he just is terrible Mitch
McConnell may be as uh you know as as
kind of brain dead as Donald Trump or
the older Republicans at this point I
don't know I mean but it's a party that
is either is both on autopilot and then
has a bunch of really stupid nihilists
uh involved and again I think Mitch
McConnell is tactically Savvy and a
reasonably intelligent political
operator
oh yeah actually MO is he just wants
Republicans to to fill seats he wants to
it's entirely about short-term electoral
calculus and there's almost that's how
you get someone dressed as a balloon yes
and there's almost no actual sort of
legislative or policy initiative there's
no principle other than you know uh but
where I think uh his mental capacity and
his political uh talents have diminished
is that uh this should have been a big
year for the Republicans including in
the Senate and he was not able to manage
the candidate selection and the you know
the races that would have helped do that
in a way that I think he has done in
previous uh moments and things like that
but you know your point is taken I mean
this is not you know Mitch you know the
Republican party doesn't stand for
anything even rhetorically anymore and
that is you know one of the great
takeaways of trump is that he came in
and was like okay you guys are the party
of limited government you're the party
of maybe immigration on some level maybe
free trade uh you know and maybe
actually interventionist foreign policy
and he's like well you're not that
anymore I've you know I've changed that
and I really do think that the younger
Republicans in the house who seem to
have some energy are just really
nihilistic they don't care about policy
they are not serious about anything and
all they like is trolling and that's you
know a party filled with Margie Taylor
greens
um is not going to be an effective
counterbalance to the status quo and
that you know in the end like I don't
I'm not particularly anti-republican
more than I am anti-democrat but this
you know and this this this kind of uh
dualism has flipped or this equation has
flipped at various points but when you
have you know you have two major parties
and when one of them is not putting up a
good coherent fight the status quo you
know maintains itself and it grows a
little bit more and more and that's one
of the reasons why we're gonna have you
know 23 of GDP spending for the next
decade uh because there's no way to to
bring that back Catherine to close out
uh this segment uh let's uh fling some
Pooh in the Democratic uh Direction uh
as well is there a nihilism or a sort of
a magical thinking ISM
um that is sort on the increase of kind
of a modern man modern monetary Theory I
can never figure out that stupid acronym
um let's just write a big check and have
that trillion dollar coin
um but looking at Social Security we
used to have Barack Obama saying that
he's not going to kick the can down the
road on his watch and now just like no
one on the Democratic side is doing this
uh criticized Democrats Catherine
delighted to I will say the people I
felt the most uh kinship with by far in
the in the room during the State of the
Union was that sort of somber faced
seated block of the Supreme Court and
like The Joint Chiefs down there like
every time everybody like started
getting up and shouting and yelling and
there was just like the the like
Stillness of that section I was like yes
this is me like we have like fight
flight or freeze and I am just
absolutely like with Team freeze at this
point
um but yeah I mean I think that the the
variant of nihilism that you see in the
Democratic party and Democratic
Leadership right now is they recognize
that there's kind of a big sales pitch
in being
anti-capitalist and and
um and I think it's not a coincidence
that some of Joe Biden's most
interestingly awkward moments both in
the speech itself and then he's done
some tweets afterward is where he has
said I'm a capitalist but
we gotta take all the money from
everyone who earned their money
in the market
um that that's out of fashion you know
he it sat awkwardly I think with what we
understand of the kind of progressive
elements of the democratic party who are
the parallels to the Marjorie Taylor
greens
um who would never say I'm a capitalist
but
um or would say like something more like
well we live in a capitalist system
that's just the reality you know they
sort of they could acknowledge it but
not be in favor of it and
um
I think we're going to see a lot more of
that I think we're going to see the
Democratic party
claiming to be anti-capitalist or at
least elements claiming to be
anti-capitalist while
absolutely doing nothing to
substantially change the system that we
exist in because it's a good one that
benefits them and they know that and
politically it wouldn't actually be
expedient to undermine it it's the same
as these Republicans well I'm for small
government but
um and they sort of start skipping that
first part eventually and that's where
we are now so I think yes there's
there's an equal kind of emptiness in
terms of broad-based like large Vision
policy goals on the part of both parties
and
you know the the other thing I thought
was like during Biden's speech you know
if you were looking at the prepared text
while he was talking the places he had
lived he repeatedly ad-libbed variants
of I know this proposal isn't really
popular with anyone but
like in several places
um because his proposals aren't really
popular with anyone like he's right
about that
um that was not sort of the right to
move tonally first state of the union
but they're not even that popular with
its own party and he knows it and he's
kind of trying to hedge that
um and then the little
Social Security was just a surprise that
fell into his lap there was a funny bit
of legislative trolling in the house a
couple weeks ago before the State of the
Union when House Republicans held a vote
to uh on a a a a bill that like wouldn't
do anything but denounced socialism in
all its forms
basically just to see how many Republic
how many Democrats would vote uh for and
against it and uh 86 voted 86 Democrats
voted against denouncing socialism in
all its forms and 14 voted present
that's really the kind of work that I'm
uh just makes me proud to be an American
all right remember uh send your uh to
the point email uh queries to Roundtable
at reason.com this one comes from
frequent correspondent Leonard goodnight
that is his real name he writes we hear
a lot in libertarian circles that
prohibition doesn't work as a rationale
for ending the drug war legalizing
abortion prostitution Etc generally I
think that's correct in principle but
there's a problem with that logic it
works too well prohibition also doesn't
work when the thing being prohibited is
murder rape robbery or arson shouldn't
those be illegal where do you draw the
line between prohibition doesn't work so
we shouldn't have this law and
prohibition doesn't work but we still
have to have this law Catherine
I think the distinction between those
two categories is how broad-based the
consensus is about which about whether
the things should be illegal um so when
I think about prohibitions and and
particularly when reason uses that term
we very very often use it to mean laws
that are at odds with the culture or
with a substantial part of the culture
everybody agrees murder should be
illegal though we disagree on the edges
of what exactly murder is and whether
the murder I want to do today
specifically should be illegal sometimes
but that is a very different matter than
say abortion which I've written about
one of the big big problems with making
abortion illegal is that people live
side by side you know their neighbors
disagree about this question and when
that happens people will see it as
morally right to oppose the law to
violate it or to support others who want
to violate it in a way that I don't
think is generally considered true for
these kind of very basic Thou shalt not
kill type rules that's an imperfect
metric of course right there are
different times in history when everyone
agreed that slavery should be legal we
all agree so no problemo here obviously
there was in fact still a problemo there
but that I think is the useful
distinction sort of when asking this
question you know will a Prohibition of
this kind succeed or fail a lot of it
hinges on are you fighting a cultural
status quo or are you operating in an op
in an environment where there is really
deeply held substantial disagreement
those are the prohibitions that fail
nick uh more to add uh yeah I mean
there's also the question of the the
type of activity we're talking about
murder is bad because it takes away
somebody's right to life you know
Liberty and I I assume the pursuit of
happiness uh drinking or doing certain
types of drugs as opposed to other types
of intoxicants doesn't it's you know
voluntary Behavior Uh freely chosen by
consenting adults and when you start to
ban those types of activities those are
the things that are going to persist in
a big way
um your murder is a rare phenomenon and
most crimes uh against people's rights
and property are relatively infrequent
something like drinking uh is not or or
drug taking and things like that um and
you know any law when it's passed needs
to be uh you know per uh Catherine's uh
kind of comments you know it needs to go
through some kind of cost-benefit
analysis because it could be a right
moral and proper law and if it's going
to become a disaster once it's
implemented you've got to really kind of
think about different ways of of
restraining that type of behavior but
with these other kind of prohibitions I
don't I don't you know I think the whole
category needs to be rethought you
shouldn't be trying to keep people from
doing behaviors that uh you know they
have every kind of moral right in a free
Society to participate it
Peter more I basically agree with Nick
that's the right distinction are are you
taking away somebody else's life
somebody else's Freedom somebody else's
property if so then it's okay to
prohibit it even if that prohibition
does not fully eliminate the activity
and in fact I think that the the one
thing I would sort of really add here is
I sometimes think that it's at least a
little bit of an error for Libertarians
to say prohibition didn't work period
with no caveats because in fact the best
evidence we have is that prohibition did
reduce drinking by something like 30 to
40 percent in the country it obviously
had an effect on alcohol consumption now
it also had a bunch of terrible side
effects and unintended consequences uh
it it turned alcohol into a black market
that was uh that was
uh a vector for a huge amount of crime
and violence
um and just sort of uh either black mark
a bad black market activity it degraded
the quality of drinks not just in a way
that was like less Artful but that was
also literally dangerous to the people
that was consuming them so it made
drinking more dangerous it also uh it
also tended to reduce drinking most
amongst people who were already light
casual non-problem Drinkers and so it
drove problem drinkers into Evermore
ever and even more dangerous drinking
situations and that's the kind of thing
that prohibitions on personal behaviors
that may in some cases have some social
negatives I mean I would say like we
have to acknowledge the existence of
problem drinkers of problem gamblers
people who have personal issues with
those things but the way to solve those
uh problems is not by prohibit by
prohibiting them by making them illegal
and throwing people in jail the way to
solve those problems is by treating
those issues individually uh and as you
know sort of as uh as personal problems
rather than by making them crimes and so
I don't know that I like that this the
sort of the the phrasing prohibition
doesn't work I think prohibition doesn't
work as intended uh prohibition has
terrible uh unintended consequences and
is ultimately worse for society is a
better way of thinking about the
problems with prohibition
doesn't fit on a bumper sticker Peter uh
all right let's go quickly to I should
probably say I have almost certainly at
some point in my life said prohibition
doesn't work
I say it all the time uh there's a big
uh Urban Institute Study last week
didn't get a lot of attention
um got some a study on public school
enrollment declines the author Thomas D
has been doing some of the best work out
there I think he's in Stanford on a
pandemic you're uh bleeding from K-12
enrollment basic takeaway is that over
the two main school years the pandemic
so beginning in the fall of 2019 and
ending in June 2022 public K-12
enrollment did not bounce back as
advertised it declined by around one
percent meanwhile to the extent that we
have the numbers and the reporters kind
of uh measures different things at their
uh Private School enrollment was up four
percent just in the last school year and
homeschooling was up 30 percent last
school year and most weirdly and this is
what attracted most of the headlines we
don't know where about 400 000 kids are
that dropped out of the system it's not
explained by going to new forms of
schooling or just by the shrinkage of
the overall school age population
Catherine you follow the stuff pretty
closely what did you find particularly
interesting or noteworthy about the
study I mean the the scale the the size
of the numbers surprised me somewhat um
I think it was entirely predictable that
if you say to a bunch of
um especially older kids you know High
School age kids and very very young kids
so um kindergarten age if you say to
their families school is absolutely
required you must go and then also say
we won't be providing School services
for a couple of years you're gonna lose
a bunch of people out of the system
they're gonna say absolutely not to hell
with this and as in the case of the
central anecdote in one of the articles
that spun out of that study they're
gonna go get a job at Chipotle because
that's a much better use of their time
than trying to do some kind of janky
online schooling
that nobody put any thought or effort
into I can't even say I blame the
Chipotle defectors frankly
um the thing that's interesting to me
punk bands the Chipotle defectors
um the thing that's interesting to me is
you know of course these students of
course these people are findable like no
one is easier to find than an American
17 year old I guarantee you that every
single one of these hundreds of
thousands of missing students have a
tick tock presence have you know a
thousand ways that you could find them
online
um it just to me it really is just like
one more blow to the myth that the thing
that public schooling is doing is
somehow creating a common cultural basis
and shared basis of knowledge for
American students it is not there are so
many ways in which people are not
participating in this system for
perfectly good reasons and this just
brought all that to the four
it pushed another batch of kids out of
the system but it's this has always been
true it has always been true that like
even if the kids bodies were in the
building they were not consuming
anything substantively that was like
making them into good American citizens
and voters they were just getting
through it and now that's not even that
and it's just it's just absurd to me
that people can still straight-facedly
say that the public education system in
the United States is like a worthy one
that we should fund more
Peter um we've been criticizing
Republicans a lot on this podcast for uh
not really having much in the way of
policies but Sarah Huckabee Sanders a
governor of Arkansas I believe
um she gave the response uh State of the
Union Spate of the Union Address
um and uh uh in between various cultural
stuff she talked basically about
education
um and she is one of the many Governors
most of them Republican
um who are kind of leading with their
chin on on aggressive school choice is
that not a republican
um like signature issue in this age
yes I think that Republican Governors uh
have an opportunity to actually make a
difference here Republican Governors
unlike Republican Senators actually have
real responsibilities to voters who are
going to make the decision about whether
to pull the lever for Republican or
Democrat who's going to be in charge of
their state who's going to be the chief
executive
um for the for their state and so
they're going to be responsive uh there
and they're going to just make you know
they're going to be engaged in the
business of governing at least somewhat
more than say Marjorie Taylor green or
Rick Scott
um uh and I I think that Democrats
handed them this opportunity and it's
really interesting that if you in some
ways if you think about it Republicans
right now are acting as Defenders of the
public school system
and Democrats and teachers unions who
have positioned themselves sort of that
way at least by in terms of messaging
over the last you know decades have uh
throughout the pandemic um teachers
unions contributed to what is what we
are now seeing as the Meltdown and
breakdown of public schooling school
closures especially the longest closures
in blue States and blue cities were
driven heavily not exclusively but
heavily by teachers unions and the
result is that people are just opting
out of public school entirely not opting
into sort of other kind of
quasi-publicly funded things your
backpack but no just opting out entirely
and that is going to cause huge problems
for the for the teachers unions that
wanted to stay home for a year or two
because of the pandemic
Nick other things to add about the study
or about the politics surrounding it uh
you know one thing that's interesting to
me uh because I went to Catholic school
but Catholic schools which uh you know
circa 1960 I think that was their Peak
year in the country uh they have been
losing people at the same or a faster
rate than uh Public Schools traditional
public schools and they actually lost
lots of kids during the pandemic uh in
the first year they actually had a
bigger loss than uh than conventional
public schools and they have a really
bounced back fully so that is to me is
kind of interesting because Catholic
schools traditionally are low um are
low-cost private schools but if you go
back to 1960 the number of kids who are
in private schools has not really
changed very much it's still stuck
around 10 percent uh what it where the
action is is in alternatives to
Conventional Public Schools some of that
is homeschooling where the numbers are
still kind of small but the growth of
publicly financed Charters
um so I think that's actually one of the
places to go and they tend to be less
unionized or not unionized at all and
then the other thing Matt I think that's
worth keeping in mind is not to pass out
I I don't know where the right
phraseology of this not to pathologize
the coveted lockdowns as the thing that
changed everything because when you look
at school districts like New York and
especially Los Angeles Unified School
District which is the second largest
District in the country they have been
losing people losing students for
decades
um because they suck and that you know
the covid uh experiences has accelerated
certain things but it's you know there
this is a long slow decline which is
kind of similar to when we were talking
about old age entitlements this these
are you know kind of systemic
slow-moving you know
arteriosclerosis type problems in
American politics today and it's not
clear I'm not as sanguine as I used to
be and even as more states have passed
by backpack funding where you know in
every state in the country education is
either the single largest or second
largest uh line item in a state budget
so when gov when things change at the
state level and money that the state was
going to be sending to a local school
district goes to a kid's parents instead
it's a big deal but I don't know I don't
know how much you know like the the
teachers unions kind of like old age
entitlements and and and conventional
schools they are in it for the long haul
it is really hard to ultimately find
that place where you know there's a
Tipping Point an actual like serious
systemic reform is going to take place
the uh in New York the uptake uh of uh
available uh parents or families to
participate in the system went from
about 67 percent in the late 90s to
about 75 percent
um under uh Mayor Bloomberg who a lot of
that is Charter School uh public charter
schools that uh brought people back into
the system and then it started uh uh
tanking again so it was uh a lot of the
long decline was uh just in terms of
population but in terms of percentage of
the population
um they had shown uh increases from the
dark old days of the 80s and 90s uh but
that is now
um uh accelerating there's a big Empire
Center
um report on that
um derived from the Thomas D study um to
talk about uh the just uh uh absolute uh
and yes pandemic related uh acceleration
over the last a couple years of exit out
of New York but a lot of that too is
that people with families just left the
city because it's why stay for a variety
of different reasons work related and
otherwise all right um at Nick
Gillespie's insistence correct
insistence I might add were making time
for a lightning round of
um yesterday was a Super Bowl big deal
in America the biggest televised
spectacle of the day year the Kansas
City Chiefs
Catherine well knows uh beat the uh
beat the San Diego pitchers was my
favorite name of a non-existent
um you either go around like Europe or
Asia there's always people with like
bogus like a chat GPT prompt uh teams uh
they're uh no they they beat the
Philadelphia Eagles
um 38-35 very exciting and so let's do a
lightning round beginning with Catherine
and her ladies book club of your very
favorite thing about the Super Bowl
yesterday I like the Ben Affleck Duncan
commercial and I will not be taking
questions about that
um yeah I mean I've enjoyed the Arc of
Ben Affleck which like now just
encompasses I think a certain
generational despair
um which I enjoy a lot and
um the tidbit that I learned about that
commercial is that apparently a bunch of
the customers at that particular donkeys
were just absolutely Furious that the
service wasn't that great that day
they greeted being served by Ben Affleck
exclusively with uh as one write-up put
it invective flecked outbursts which is
a try to say that three times fast yeah
I I that's all I'm here for I'm here for
like despairing Ben Affleck serving me
donkeys and like just super casual
Rihanna like she was just like she was
marking the steps she was walking
through low energy screw you she was
chill she was just like yeah I'm Rihanna
I'm pregnant and I'm playing the Super
Bowl what do you want I'm amazing you're
welcome that I'm here and I think we
should all bring that energy into 2023.
yeah
uh Nick you'll agree with me that was no
dunkaccino uh performance by Ben Affleck
yeah no no that's for sure uh what was
your favorite part of the spectacular
yesterday well I I'll start with my the
biggest disappointment I was pregnancy
and all I thought that Rihanna was going
to uh disrobe to some kind of you know
creative uh effect yeah her coat just
got bigger
I
I am not here for low energy halftime
shows uh you know and I one of the
things I went back uh it was only really
in the uh 90s that Super Bowl halftime
shows became like big big things the 90s
was a long time ago
yeah it's for if the 90s are closer to
Pearl Harbor yes than we are yes I mean
like everything is closer to Pearl
Harbor and you're sorry I'm starting to
think like maybe you know we need Pearl
Harbor to generate more activity but
like Pete Fountain the jazz player oh
God like he he appeared at the Grand
League State University marching band
have appeared like they they were
appearing in the halftime shows into the
90s and it's just like what the hell is
going on like uh you know the halftime
show I liked last year's which got
trashed because it was seen as like a
Gen X
sell editor was fantastic you know so I
didn't like that uh what I want to come
for is I had to end up watching the end
of the game on ESPN Gamecast uh which is
a uh they've had it for years I just it
it's kind of like an old 80s style uh
handheld video game it's like watching
that and I loved you know the last
minute or two on Gamecast where you get
these slow moving diagrammatic updates
of what happened and it's so exciting to
watch a game that was as close as that
one on Gamecast that know that you know
it's like the light from a dying star in
a different galaxy you know you're
receiving it long after everybody
involved is dead it was really great so
that's what I liked about that is a
beautiful and poetical uh Peter what was
your favorite uh moment uh William's
sister selling whiskey ads I didn't
watch it
yeah
but since your favorite what's up uh
Pearl Harbor I just want to say oh no
but it's I hate this transition for us
it is Michael Bay's worst movie
and to bring this full circle kind of
peak Ben Affleck in a certain way
I think what we saw yesterday it was
Peak Ben Affleck that's what I'm saying
yeah yeah no I think he was also in a
commercial for uh the uh the the making
of how Nike landed the Air Jordan
um there's a Ben Affleck picture coming
out
um yes I think it's true as long as
we're talking about about Ben Affleck is
from this point forward he's going to be
known as somebody uh he's going to be
known as a Matt Welch impersonator
that's right rather than the other way
around thank you I hope you're seeing my
achievements I hope you'll put that
story in today's show notes where I'll
see Matt Welch tried out to be a uh Ben
Affleck in person I was recruited sir uh
okay uh my favorite part of the Super
Bowl
uh uh part of you know ongoing
middle-aged sogginess uh was
um uh as it went from like the pregame
show to the the whatever the they called
it the uh the pre-kickoff portion of the
of the programming uh they had uh some
uh voiceover of Johnny Cash narrating a
poem about the tattered flag
um and uh and all this footage and just
like well she's she's gone through a lot
this kind of stuff and there's like the
that whole section and then just going
through like baby face for some reason
playing a guitar left-handed America the
Beautiful wow with like 75 chord changes
key changes uh and then it goes to Chris
uh Stapleton
um playing great version absolutely
great version on electric guitar of uh
and singing of the national anthem
causing the Philadelphia Eagles head
coach oh I forget Giovanna Ribisi or
something whatever his name is just ugly
Cry he's just like bawling on the
sidelines well this this fat country
dude is just warbling out wonderfully uh
I loved all and then then a red flyover
of a lady or a lady
Arab Navy pilot gals uh just I loved
every little bit of the Americana over
the top Schmaltz at the beginning I'm
here for that I'm disappointed that up
with people didn't participate or that
the Chinese air balloons didn't fly over
that would have been nice there was a
Children's Chorus I should say who were
also like well the Johnny Johnny Cash
was talking about she she's looking okay
then like the panda the kids chorus uh
doing ums and Oz love it uh 10 out of 10
no notes all right let's go to what
other culture we have been consuming out
there in the world Nick once you start
us off
uh okay so I read and now I need to find
it again uh the Fantastic new book by
Verlin Lewis and Hiram Lewis I don't
know what their relation is but they're
two separate people separate but equal
uh that it was called the myth of left
and right how the political spectrum
misleads and harms America
Matt Welch I want to remind you of a
book that was published about a decade
ago maybe 12 years ago called the
Declaration of Independence this brings
the receipts that we uh you know failed
to uh you left like stuffed in the
bottom of your wallet you know that book
yeah to Michael Bay's Pearl Harbor than
we are to this book
uh or two Pearl Harbor itself uh but it
is
um the myth of left and right how the
political spectrum misleads and harms
America is a fantastic uh book of
political science and it is these guys
are not pushing a Libertarian
alternative to things but when they talk
about how people who call themselves
conservative or liberal right or left
Republican or Democrat attempt to
essentialize these categories and it is
uh it is something that needs to be read
and understood by everybody in a
political journalism uh kind of
Enterprise uh because this clarifies so
much about why our political discourse
is just rancid and useless and
upfuscatory
um the one thing that I will add and
this is uh having had several uh
conversations with Jonathan height what
is interesting is when you look at the
you know political specter room or
political tribes from a political point
of view as opposed to a psychological
view you get different readings and what
height and other people somebody like
Karen Stenner who used to be at
Princeton and wrote a book called The
authoritarian Dynamic years ago we'll
talk about is that you know
psychologically there are certain types
of people who kind of are going to be
have certain types of uh temperaments or
predilections that get expressed in
certain types of political outlooks like
conservative and liberal and things like
that are libertarian and authoritarian
and that's important and that's an
essential part of understanding politics
but the myth of left and right how the
political spectrum misleads and harms
America by Verlin Lewis and Hiram Lewis
really explains the politics of the
current moment and why the two parties
don't seem to be particularly different
from one another but act as if they are
absolutely you know you know the devil
versus Angels or something like that
really good book Peter what did you
consume so I watched Magic Mike's Last
Dance the third film in the magic mic
franchise you know it's it's a movie
about male strippers and middle-aged
female empowerment and six-pack abs but
as it turns out it's also a movie about
zoning
and historical review boards and why
they're bad
and I I wasn't expecting that I really
wasn't at all though maybe I should have
been because this movie like the first
one uh is directed by Stephen sonderberg
who is one of the great observers of uh
of of Modern Life and one of the great
movie directors of the last 30 years or
so in part because whatever budget level
he is working at he always manages to
find some way to to add in some sort of
foresaw of reality right like his movies
seem even even at their most ridiculous
always seem to take place in something
like a real and recognizable world with
real and recognizable characters and I
want to be clear this is a completely
absurd and completely ridiculous movie
but it has a lot of small sharply
observed little bits in it in particular
the way that uh historical preservation
review boards are basically used as
political tools by powerful people to
stop stuff that they don't like that
other people are doing not to actually
preserve historical thing things in a
way that like makes any kind of sense
and so this is a movie about a uh a
wealthy older woman who hires a stripper
to conduct a male dance review at the um
the historical theater that her husband
kinda owns but she has become um the the
she she now runs as part of a kind of
divorce type settlement and she's like
this is a this is a way of getting
revenge on her husband and trying to
make him mad and so what he does is he
uses his political connections including
going up to like MPS in the British
Parliament to try and stop this thing
from happening not by like you know
making a big moral issue about it but by
saying at one point that the stripper
stage that they'd built was three
quarters of an inch too high and
therefore they're gonna have to shut
down the whole thing and it's actually
that's that is how a lot of zoning and
like sort of historical review stuff
works it's not really about the
preservation of the of the neighborhood
character or some something important
it's about somebody is mad that somebody
else is trying to do something that is
interesting and Innovative and they're
using their political connections to get
it shut down it's not exactly a great
movie
um but it's fun and uh and better than I
expected and again just really sort of
sharply and amusingly observed and
Channing Tatum is a genuinely Charming
dude uh at all times
listening to Peter I loved uh
soderberg's first movie Sex Lies and
zoning boards yeah it's a classic which
came out I think closer
um
listening to Magic Mike three uh
reference to it um is kind of like you
know like if you follow New York post on
Twitter which is the world's greatest
newspaper at least America's
um but it's always like uh you know this
celebrity just Dunked On That Celebrity
about having an affair with this
celebrity and you've juice recognized
absolutely nobody in the story at all it
feels really great the fact that there's
this is the third in the Magic Mike
Trilogy like okay that's great I've
checked out of whatever this is
um oh no now the Magic Mike I I Peter I
uh appreciate your review because I'm a
big Magic Mike fan and uh you know that
way they have the Magic Mike
franchisement was instrumental in
Reviving Matthew McConaughey uh you know
it's also a great portrait of kind of of
crappy Tampa and the and the the
weirdness of the Tampa economy where
you've got all these guys who are like
well I'm sort of a stripper but I also
do construction and maybe I'm trying to
start a furniture store and it's just
it's a great movie about like a an under
uh a place that doesn't get a lot of
attention in Hollywood and it actually
seems like to to have taken an interest
in the people there again Soderbergh is
is a sharp Observer of real humans and
their real lives there's a great little
bit where like one of the characters is
like I'm a Medicaid Insurance
administrator or something like that and
it's just like oh those are the types of
jobs people actually have in Tampa
and you don't see that in a lot of films
Catherine what do you got I have a
sports ball that is not the Super Bowl
um I want to recommend to people I've
talked about it before maybe
um Kareem Abdul-Jabbar's sub stack
that's what I'm recommending to you uh
you're so mad you're so mad at him
because he is my Nemesis he beats me
every year for the Los Angeles Press
Club columnist of the Year award every
year every single year he beats me it's
fine
um because of that I took an interest in
Lebron James's uh beating of his NBA
scoring record if I can't do it at least
LeBron can do it for me and
um went to read the uh fairly
substantial piece that Kareem
Abdul-Jabbar wrote on his sub stack
about having his record broken and once
again infuriatingly it is absolutely
gentlemanly Charming
gracious thoughtfully written and
um I hate it so uh I recommend to you
Kareem Abdul-Jabbar's subject he says in
the subsection why I'm thrilled that
LeBron broke the record whenever a
sports record is broken including mine
it's time for celebration it means that
someone has pushed the boundaries of
what we thought possible to a whole new
level and when one person climbs higher
than the last person we all feel like we
are capable of being more he's right and
it's cool to celebrate human
accomplishment
fine
Kareem Abdul-Jabbar a gentleman a
scholar
a Victor even in defeat
he also brushes back Magic Johnson a
little bit he does he says he's but he's
like again so gracious he's like my
friend we have been friends for so long
if he said anything I would believe him
he is unfortunately slightly mistaken in
with regard to whether or not I am mad
about this record being broken and
that's totally fair because had it been
broken some years ago I would have been
hyper competitive and angry about it and
probably done something crappy but now
I'm 75 and I have wisdom and so I have
moved Beyond these Petty grievances it's
he's good Matt
I know I read it it's very good um I
just want to register my surprise that
neither Catherine on her current uh
religion Journey nor Nick on whatever
Journey he's been taking uh
mentioned the two uh some of the
greatest Super Bowl ads there was about
Jesus Jesus Jesus had some good
commercials during the Super Bowl uh go
check it out I'll leave it at that I did
I did Baptist this weekend by the way
with uh Jason Russell our esteemed
managing editor uh the cool Baptist as
he described them and they were indeed
props to the cool Baptist of Clarendon
uh again band names up and down uh what
I saw and I saw sitting next to Nick
Gillespie
it was uncharacteristically quiet
um during this the only checking his
phone sometimes and not asleep and not
asleep usually there's a little
snorkeling sound uh when you sit next to
neck at a movie theater we saw uh a
fantastic movie called pinball the man
who saved the game yes
um and it's by the Bragg brothers who
work for reason Meredith and Austin
Bragg I wouldn't just say that because
they work with them I would say if
anything there are Matt uh Damon and Ben
Affleck uh very much so uh it is the
story of Roger sharp who is the
spectacularly mustachioed uh GQ
journalist uh and pinball player
um or the would be I guess he ended up
having a pretty decent career but he
helped uh overturn New York City's
ridiculous and are you kidding me they
really had this uh 35 year ban on
pinball uh in 1976 and it's just sort of
the story about how that happened and
it's also a love story and it also has
these single great and I hope they win
an Oscar just for this cinematic
deployment of a bad finger song in the
history of uh of film
um it is uh it's terrific it's just
really funny and warm spirited and I uh
I've just uh can't say enough about it
it's the beginning it's uh theatrical
release sometime soon it's on the
festival circuit and doing very well we
there was a special uh screening that we
watched in Manhattan and just great and
uh go check it out pinballfilm.com is
the place where you can go and find out
more information about it but it's just
really funny and nice
yeah it'll be uh coming to video on
demand in March 17th Matt Welch okay
that's great
um all right thank you for listening to
this slightly longer version of uh the
reason Roundtable podcast uh check out
all our podcasts at origin.com podcasts
uh Nick anything coming up in New York
City that you would like to invite
people to after your spectacular triumph
last week with cat Roosevelt uh on March
9th uh we will be having a reason
Speakeasy Thursday March 9th with
Anthony scaramucci oh well we'll be
talking about why this is going to be
the greatest year ever for uh Bitcoin
and other forms of cryptocurrency as
well as uh talking some trash about a uh
a queen's uh real estate developer who
once uh led a little country called
America that uh is very exciting okay
thank you for listening we'll catch you
next week goodbye
done
[Music]
bye